não é tese clubes com vocês
veja se o caso de escrever
a do desequilíbrio e nesta cozinha
frases que o sinal do que está
assistindo eu tenho nenhuma
então vou ter que puxar por mim mesmo
o equilíbrio pra mim é apenas
determinadas situações funciona nos
outros na maioria das situações vasco
com um declínio tanto erro sai da rotina
nós tínhamos de rotina que quase dez
patentes por isso que discutimos aqui
nas classes e clima legal está cansado
desligá lo em função como vamos ver uma
foto e publicar as fotos falsas de
mércia grave e inconsciente - passa por
três fases
vou passar a apresentar agora na nesta
toca só perceber que só possível porque
eu estou falando que estava num sabe o
quanto estava na sala
conseguimos terminar a apresentação
aconteceu porque o primeiro clipe do
disco grandes histórias têm por mim é
completamente é completamente
desnecessário na manhã de ontem o olhar
um olhar nossa visão do vira uma visão
do nosso lado do produto não é
fundamental desenvolver sem passar
produtos nem de apresentar marcas o
bastão para mim eu estava me apresentar
esta câmera capta uma câmera que
gostamos bastante vai ter mais que o
tempo passe mais que o tempo passe livre
nos ônibus
fujifilm esta continua a ser a melhor
câmera estava na agência e custa os
olhos da cara não gosta mesmo dela e com
um material que hoje em dia
completamente obsoletos estava sem
munição
esta foto foi tirada nos açores o vulcão
dos capelinhos
você já foi lá e eu cheguei no local
local espaço enquanto presta rocha aqui
né brinca um fator que eu comecei a
porção de virar as costas e não se
encaixavam no na guiné nesta parte que
faltava
e quando por mim eu tirar mais curta lua
nova que eram 50 na altura foi assim com
essa assimetria
esta foto foi tirada com o 4s ou quatro
vezes antes de se chegar a uma batata
que importa num repórter visamos mas
disse ter se inspirado com gláucia 3310
com o resultado mesmo que as que não têm
muita paciência espanha é mais a idéia
tratamento com documental e se eu
estivesse como máquina está em cuba
se tivesse uma máquina como fugitivo com
que tem hoje em dia um público entre
elas têm hoje em dia eu realmente não
ter mestrado em uma foto o fato pelo
tamanho da ajuda muito neste aspecto que
quase marcou com o no bolso se ele fez
alguma coisa de ram estivesse da
cimatron por um nome por enfrenta uma
onda de palmeirina foto nem está em
marrocos sozinho desastroso - o 1
trilhão um gol qualquer
mas exemplo esta foi a décima taxa
natural de marrocos só com o telemóvel
não é uma série que eu fiz que só com
uma pessoa no final da viagem ele faz
falta de kim está no fato de uma pessoa
acontece que esta foto
nesta quinta uma nova turma tá bom
e essa foto aqui como podem ver um
formato um trio de frente também tirar
com uma tradução
essa foi a visão de que as faltas que
teria uma máquina máquina cava com um
vitória leva os comentários do
parlamentar é lk nesse caso e tenta
tirar fotos com o mais importante é
estar esta foto face detection parque
infantil em marraquexe e eu espero que o
governo do parque diz que envia as
crianças leiam em esquetes a brincar
disse patten que tem que tirar uma foto
e no momento em que compõem a máquina
por trás do numerados
as crianças vêem com você pra valer
neste momento a sida com maldonado tinha
máquina do do olho nós começamos atrás
de mim e eu andando
o secretário sempre atrás de nós nem
três nem traz me transmitiu que chamou a
si o que você vai fazer 11 uma bolinha
de 15 aconteceu no 15 lugar no final
vamos plantar que queriam ver só com a
sua primeira falta comenta estamos
vivendo é muito mais grave se tivesse eu
fosse um leque de ter consigo pensar
muito mais grave ter acontecido uma
coisa muito mais graves do que aconteceu
mas isso quer dizer que se eu tivesse
que está novamente se passavam por
amsterdã eu estava no trabalho no
facebook o vidro google maps não me
ensinaram tudo isso é só mostrar que uma
vez feito o processo de 2011 é o
pavimento é um fotógrafo do público
também já falou em uma toca em suma é
assim mesmo só uma visão e estejam
batista 908 mesmo nisto passado após um
grande clube que é o atual
como devem calcular você só vocês já
viram fotos instagram não nos convém
colocar poderá fazer se tem lata
hum esse senhor aqui na falta para essa
menina está completamento passado não
estava na praia e eu tava no estava num
minha atual equipe a bater uma foto na
altura uma marca e cria fazer o punk
fazer essa brincadeira do de especificar
ainda fica além do corpo a ser maior
o pessoal não surpreende ninguém para
tirar a parceria está na foto porque o
estado estava com fome e em um esse
dinheiro que só são 11 o quarto veio
depois e pior em favor de alguém mais
novas que aparecem na foto é um senhor o
vazamento disse em um texto curto 20
empresta imagem
então eu realmente estivesse sentindo
ensino e não merece falou eu não
consegui ter esta família está faltando
aqui foi tirar a frente é que a fachada
que a s&p 500 princípio o governo do meu
filho só para ficar no foco
antes a tv que esta missão de ilusão do
respectiva e esse é o miguel franco é um
milhão mas sim mas sim apartamentos
princípio nisto mais uma vez fui
explicar a falta no final como resultado
a pessoa que está no avaí
estou é que esta não seja muito bairros
pentacampeã
isso aqui é um bairro nos açores uma
praia uma praia central e euro e apontar
a câmera me colocaram de volta por cima
tem que ter que acontecer então eu volto
e do dodô volta limpa ele iria apagar a
filha forma
no final ela terá nesta foto aqui está
morto no ano 680 de tvs minuto 55 trava
foto tvs minutos casa passaram a olhar
para mim a designar o empresário
é preciso que vocês conseguem aguentar
90 minutos acabando como aquela que
tamanho orgulho foi inoculado letras
como as pessoas a passarem usadas na
praia do evento da silva vendas muitas
pessoas apesar do problema ser
equilíbrio é fundamental é preciso um
grande debate por exemplo basta ir a um
café entre as garrafas estão à mingua
saltava quase consegue tirar uma foto
mas eu vou gastar mais dinheiro né pra
fazer alguma coisa para ser um dos
melhores a fazer isso por vezes se sente
sempre mais por aí
então essa questão está no grupo a
participar temos que ver os restantes
que sempre mais
na foto a seguir instintivamente pai
comprar uma goma comprou 14 anos um café
da manhã que será necessário ball fechar
uma rua inteira de bons e vamos
habituando começa no domingo estarei
aqui uma foto que encontra sempre
perguntam consegue fazer umas fotos com
ela consegue falar agora mas que sempre
tenta descobrir finalmente e essa
situação segundo ano como é que surgiu
sempre que fazia uma viagem me
perguntava o fim do ano pois traz a luta
nós temos as fotos tiradas
a chuva não é nossa mas pelas fotos
tiradas gira de dirigir a mesma que o
tesouro no 13 mais ágil não faltasse
mais normal
agora como está a minha mas são estas
fotos
a comissão é essa aqui nesta coluna
online anos
a história agora aguarda esta é falta de
mote à minha mãe até virado ao contrário
de um homem salva assim mais sintomático
do mato e tarumã do google esta ilha
onde foi filmado star wars por exemplo
tem que ser
estamos cada vez mais que está em uma
das casas têm um tamanho
por exemplo aqui falta normal de aula
também está sempre à mão tá ruim vocês
passem a votar basta ganhar empatar aqui
não tem nem sempre à mão
essa é a nossa espécie
no oriente
marcelo biato o tempo e tudo pode ser
original mesmo visitar tudo pode ser um
teste office mesmo podem tirar uma foto
quando consegue observar gostava de
fazer muito mais mas basicamente são
essas pedras na linha e se o 11 minutos
enquanto a minha camisa com o custo as
calças dela ficou assim até o momento
esteve em marketing acidente ao momento
somente como tem sido demonstrado a nota
explica que a procura por faltas tóquio
descreveu o plano como o desempenho de
frente e primeira fase em que fala do
quanto do batom é é que não vou mudar em
tirar fotos são do tipo marcas num novo
colega tite não admite ele
somente as próximas disseram que vão
procurar pois procura iniciado por isso
não possa salvar título porém coisas que
eu quero saber é se ele começa a faltar
folga é a forma mais fácil de andar em
lisboa estranhou né não os franceses no
clube
as vidas mas também muito grande difícil
do milan estampa marca de 720 mil e está
logo aí aparece um elemento muito tempo
de espera como marca de jeans
destaque para entrar logo em campo é
fator a se pagar pelo exército cercar
uma marquise profissionais passa a
torcer para o flamengo
que o diga o erro com vocês para
revitalizar o equilíbrio
eu acho isso muito tempo eu acho que os
erros são uma das grandes fontes de tira
teima em dizer que acontece aqui e
chegada no quartel da graça na peça fogo
tem uma foto linda no partenon
em vez de lamentar o fato de as obras
devem tratar que tem como brincar e
defender o tempo lua encontra se na rua
alcântara em são gonçalo
se não é melhor
a vítima uma parede faz pensar que uma
top bitch inclui o time dessa situação é
o que vamos falar muitas chamas porque é
uma coisa que eu nunca realmente
apaixonada por sombras porque a questão
mas nunca são iguais na memória além de
vocês pra uma inglesa uma invenção já
mudou completamente
atualmente na por ban partirá de fato é
que eu queria essa fatura passar na rua
como momento você vive
faltava contrário tentava cantar em
trânsito
esta sombra cruzará o que elas querem
nenhum filme fiz não posso ter um
usuário mais à sombra
não é uma ilha e que sempre viu a
fundação do estado ficou lá tornou o
primeiro tirar documentos como é que vai
tirar fotos é uma janela igual
estas são duas colegas se fosse lá mas
também não resultava outros por isso foi
encaminhado ao hospital do andaraí que o
pico da batalha final da ponte 25 de
abril a saída para as portagens também
gostava de ter exatamente o que é uma
zona de passagem não consegue demonstrar
que o senhor espera para 2010 a saúde
não conseguiu tirar do meu time para
testar a máquina am em ok aqui
trabalhando passeio mais pequeno num
novo teste e passei metade da viagem
tentaram ganhar a corda com pontos em
abril
como vocês podem ver aqui a câmara tem
que separar as coisas é que isso e se
apresentava a passar eu via cessão do
espaço tem mesmo de tirar a foto do
rapaz apareceu para a única o euro
conseguirá assim se tivesse pressa por
controlar o país a entrar nesse clima
das fotos por meio destas fotos com
muita paciência mas de talento ou mais
do que outra coisa qualquer e power mix
com muita paciência é tirar também é
tirado essa paciência de tirar nunca
teve um plano claro que eu queria agora
com as coisas fazer com que suas sanções
- menina quanto ao tratamento a água
conta quanto tempo nós vamos sair
daquela situação descrita há cinco dias
e 20 horas acordado em 25 13 e 18 horas
a lei março é grave
sete meses é de 27 c duas horas nas
filas quatro anos 90 dias caiu que irá
perder tempo terá faltas por isso a
receber um tiro perto mesmo tempo os
novatos na proteína que é uma criança
que está em uma encosta o fato como não
estava sic com
um longo tempo mas sempre tive com muita
paciência
aqui está uma posição melhor na classe
que não ligam saltaram 5 casar daqui a
100 anos
estou muito tempo a chegar aqui e estava
no porto de ficar o time geninho e
espero compartilhar passar segurança
para seu ganho a estátua é que não passe
mesmo tamanho de um livro bom ainda por
a mão ea bomba se aproximou os atletas
mineiros que estão acampadas ao colo
antes de estar a atirar também contra a
falta de uma amiga só tá tudo acertado
era bom o butantan
o clube catalão incluiu o conforto é
esse risco já criavam twitter a foto
aqui tirar fotos aqui foi nessa
instância da planilha de inventar uma
área privada de segurança começou a
correr atrás de nós em nossa fazenda
maurício toledo social e itália foto
então percebeu que estávamos ali eles 11
a chance de chegar aqui estão estão 1110
bastidores da história privada também
gostaram tanto que é uma conduta da
cozinha de apresentar aqui eu estava com
o ps nesta graça e meu companheiro e
taurina da vida e da família sim eu
estava ali só de amor às vezes alguns
riachos que tem visto até hoje como
sinais na espanha deve ser o brasil
aqui não falta simples essa falta pode
ser atribuído à constante declarou
a unitau de uma boa série desta forma
será a única arena primário em 2010 mas
que não está em questão está o único gol
em todo momento para ser a tentativa mas
cantou apenas uma amiga minha me parece
me incrível virada
essa foto aqui perto no local de
trabalho e eu passava todos os dias é um
dia de festa ficar completa falta com
isso
vai ter que ter os cuidados práticos e
que mais parece um dinossauro andava de
bicicleta é uma sombra do milhão
esta prenda que você não vê traços do
passado ano de trabalho
saiba todos prestam preta mas preto na
selva de narita mas não teve aula não
assinaria por fotos vencer a entrevista
porém após cumprir você vá tomar o poder
o boninho festa carnaval aplicativo fica
na parte que coube a um ator como um
potencial negócio é a primeira visita
que faz ao menos dizer o que eu queria
mesmo era o principal entrave
significativo porque não quer dizer que
vão estar os profissionais nem que seja
um dos melhores gramados
basta ter um smartphone basta ter visão
total de televisão antes atrás santos é
nossa visão não sei se fazer sentir a
nossa visão essa não é uma boa não só
para ilustrar uma edição do fazendo com
alguns traços patativa por isso acho que
esse tempo motivação para dar uma única
gonçalves da cunha saque mas não possa
mostrar a nossa saúde estará a primeira
falta contra este grande vocês realmente
vão perceber que fazem você se torna se
a primeira falta que o país tenha
ensinado muitas vezes passa antes da
história com os pés
a apresentação dos locais todos os
locais todos os materiais são úteis a
quem vai ser nossa visão é difícil
[Aplausos]